huh
oh that's nice that's good water
hope everybody is doing all right uh let
me know that you can hear me okay i know
i've screwed that up uh
previously
so it never hurts to double check
can see and hear me wonderful
hope everybody's doing well
i
made the decision to
not
dedicate a video to
san diego comic-con um
there is a lot to unpack so we are going
to talk about it uh i decided to do this
instead of making a video because
i'm buried in work and did not have the
time or the energy to devote another
shoot and edit uh and cram it in with
all the stuff i'm already trying to do
ah
uh but uh in any case
we got
a lot to go over i i am going to like be
glancing at um
pretty much
everything that was announced i'm i
won't have things to say about
um
about some of it because some of it i
don't care
uh
so there is that
salvera regina thank you jack remember
for five months appreciate you sticking
around um and this will be the reminder
that um
comments uh i do try and keep up with
the chat but the only thing that
guarantees that a comment will be
red
um uh or a question responded to
would be if you um use a super chat you
also get a heart from me for doing so
so uh and any i don't care is still
saying something i suppose so
i suppose so
so
oh boy we've got a lot to look at here
so
let me switch this over
and
yeah okay so
first thing
that is uh that's right there is
something that uh i'm not gonna talk
about
i don't care about avatar lego sets i
mean like they they look kind of cool
i uh i won't lie about that they do look
interesting but i'm not really that into
lego and my kid moved on from it so and
she definitely has no interest in avatar
so uh no real thoughts there
after that first look at the characters
from dungeons and dragons on or among
thieves i suspect that the um
that the actual trailer will be brought
up later i was
uh i was surprised how much i liked the
uh the look of the trailer
it it has just a really fun it has the
vibe that well
frankly that a uh dungeons and dragons
movie should have it feels like a bunch
of people who just get along going on an
adventure that is what dungeons and
dragons the game at its best feels like
that is what any dungeons and drive
dragons movie should feel like
hey very i got some terrible news my dog
cosmo whom i've known since
he was a pub passed away recently at age
17 i've been sad past couple days
i'm very sorry logan
and i wish you for the best going
forward
michael anderson doyle
good to see you dharma
thank you for keeping up the uh the sub
the member subscription and uh of course
wonderful entrance as always
so uh let's see what else we've got here
teenage mutant ninja turtles the
cowabunga collection has a release date
okay so
if this is good
i will get it the thing is though i am
going to wait for reviews to come out
because
there is little doubt in my mind that
konami is throwing this together
relatively quickly to capitalize on the
success of shredders revenge that came
out earlier this year
uh but
the thing is
i don't trust konami to do anything even
throw together a bunch of roms of old
games into a collection so
we'll see what happens
uh with that
oh also with the dungeons and dragons
movie there'll be no thora bird suddenly
forgetting how to act in this one so
that's a plus
whoo
boy yeah that movie
it it was like um jeremy irons
sapped thor burch's acting ability in
order to amplify his own and go as much
over the top as possible he was like an
acting vampire
oh that that movie was a trip
all right
dungeon dragon's honors among thieves
san diego comic-con clips reveals a
battle with the classic 1980s cartoon
party
okay
i mean that's cute i never watched that
cartoon but that's cute in theory
another thing about d d oh the trailer
i'm not gonna play any of these trailers
because that'll get the um that'll get
the live stream shut down for copyright
nonsense so i will not be doing any of
that um however i did see this trailer
and it's fun
it's uh it was a lot of fun which was
just nice
transformers not my thing
okay so i don't have too much to say uh
in regards to
their
being uh the the actual teaser for this
national treasure tv series
i
i am kind of uh
kind of interested to see how it turns
out though i have a soft spot for well i
have a soft spot for treasure hunt
stories in the first place and i do have
soft spot for national treasure so i i
am curious to see how this ends up going
jeremy irons was the only good thing
about that movie jeremiah's was not good
in that movie he was one of the few fun
things about that movie but that's
good no
no
ah
[Music]
uh i cried when the black panther 2
teaser dropped oh yeah i'm sure we'll
get to that
uh so let's see what else
was it oh so this was this this was
interesting so the first clip for
moon girl and devil dinosaur
it
i don't think i'm going to like it it's
it's a little bit
too
high energy it's a little bit too
bombastic
i think it looks like it knows what it
wants to be and i think it's probably
going to be a pretty good version of
that
i just i think it's probably aimed at a
demographic and an age range that is not
me
so like i watched the the clip and i'm
like this is fun but this would get
exhausting for me to try and watch and
so that's probably something i'll skip
but don't have a problem with it
existing
uh
how are you feeling about the
thunderbolts marvel phase five new we'll
get to marvel marvel's gonna eat up a
whole lot of this stream we'll get there
don't you worry
uh
jeremy is i just bought a castle
apparently and needed the money
i guess i guess that's what you get with
uh with english actors as you know
um you get with american actors you get
um
uh nick cage needing to cover his tax
bills and then you get jeremy irons they
need to pay off a castle gotham nice
gameplay trailer i'm never gonna play
that game so i don't care
william shatner to appear in masters of
the universe revolution
cool
i don't think we know who he's playing
um and there is much more known about
that humans of the master universe
season three season three when the heck
was there a season two
i haven't watched that either it's it
didn't really look like it was uh
anything like this was this was the
version of masters of the universe that
was like intended to actually bring in
new fans as opposed to cater to the old
ones which again i have no problem with
that existing just you know i am an
existing fan so
uh something about severance i don't
watch it wheel of time i don't watch it
severance
beavis and butthead don't care
king of the hill
creator don't care mighty morphin power
rangers and teenage men mutant ninja
turtles sequel coming in december
so like
it'd be a stretch to say that i care
about that cause i don't um
i've never really followed mighty
morphin power rangers past the first
season and so you know ages of agents
and ages ago
but that's fun as a concept so i'm fine
i'm fine with it being a thing
uh i've never been that into d d if you
want my reasoning see mabel from gravity
falls fair enough it's not for everybody
oh i
miss this news about shatner's chatter's
just being a turd in general i don't
really plan to to deal with that because
i don't wanna
spongebob squarepants universe gets a
crossover since what
since when does spongebob even have a
universe like whatever
i
i don't care
national treasure edge of history gets
official behind the scenes featurette i
didn't watch that but i did catch uh
that the character of riley is coming
back so i like that as a connection uh
to the old films
dc seemingly has no has no plans to make
more snider verse movies this
this is something that we are going to
be hearing
about from a certain segment of the
internet very loudly for a while but
like it's hard to blame them because
look here's the thing
no matter how successful
the uh zack snyder cut of justice league
was
and by most measures the best as we can
tell because
you know hbo max like every streaming
platform does not make public their
actual viewing numbers um it was
successful especially for at the time it
came out when hbo max was first
launching in terms of getting people
interested in trying out the platform
but
the idea of the expense
of trying to
bring that back in and not to mention
like would it run in parallel to the
other stuff they're doing would they try
and get the stuff that has kind of gone
off and become a bit of its own thing
like the suicide squad and shazam and
wonder woman would they try and and
wrench that back into the snider verse
like i especially after having gone
through a merger like warner brothers
did recently i don't see them
um
[Music]
i don't see them
spending the money on that i never did
ah
so moving on ah crap i said i didn't
want to deal with shatner and there it
is right there william shatner goes off
on star trek gene roddenberry would be
turning in his grave
the reason gene roddenberry would have
been turning in his grave is because
there aren't enough huge alien ball
sacks on tv as much as he would have
wanted
and apparently he added
into that [ __ ] star wars like shatner at
this point seems to just decide
he seems to have decided he's an
80-something troll
which to me is just kind of sad
multi-versus don't care
okay so
lord of the rings the rings of power
there was a new trailer i did look at it
i've kind of been avoiding talking about
this thing
too much
because
honestly
i'm
i don't feel much pulled towards it
uh oh adrenaline thank you so much for
the super chat hi vera i hope you had a
nice rest i did a lot of driving so it
was arguable how restful it was but
looking forward to the twitch streams
again yep they'll be back tomorrow
um
so
here's i think is the thing with or at
least for me for me let me be very clear
if you are excited about um the lord of
the rings stuff the continuation the
fact that it looks visually to be very
much coherent with the peter jackson
movies
great
that's kind of what bores me though the
thing is that those movies when they
came out were
revolutionary
they set a new standard but the problem
is that new standard is still the
standard
that style of sweeping vistas that
degree of
uh integration of special effects with
live action that let's let's swoop the
camera around and show you all of this
majesty that is now what is standard and
while
thankfully for me it hasn't diminished
how good lord of the rings still is
i
just am not wrapped up in that
presentation anymore and then i'm just
reminded by the fact that ultimately
when it comes to tolkien's actually
actual work
it's kind of a little bit of a minor
miracle that i like lord of the rings
movies as much as i do because really
the only thing tolkien
wrote that i actually enjoyed reading
was the hobbit
so given that i'm now over the visual
presentation of these things and we're
just left with the lore and the
mythology and the stories i just don't
care very much for me that's me just me
also shirley snyder himself does not
want to work with warner brothers he
doesn't sound like he had a great time
with him so if i was a fan of his i
would think that was good news well
it kind of depends because as a noted
they just went through a merger and
there's still some shifting sands
so
he might potentially uh be
coming at it
from an angle of well you know there the
things have been shaken up and maybe
there's new management coming in or
maybe he's hoping new management will
come in or maybe he's hoping that if
they say yes to him again they're not
going to screw him this time because
eyes are really going to be on them and
how they're managing things but like i
don't know it's i i have a hard time
parsing what it is snyder does or
doesn't want to do right now
it's i'm i'm haven't really been able to
to
get into the guy's head very well
disney's making a new musical movie
called penelope it's suzy based on
princess and the p what are your
thoughts i have no thoughts miss wicked
wolf you have to stop asking me
questions about like what are my
thoughts on this has been announced okay
unless i know who's making it who the
talent is maybe or if i'm already
familiar with the source material or if
there's a trailer i have no thoughts
i don't i don't know what you want from
me
all right moving on that was a little
over the top but like you you do this to
me a lot you ask me questions that i'm
like
why do you expect me to have an opinion
on that
original gremlins star zach galligan
will return for secret secrets of the
mogwai
which is an animated series
huh
this is a project that
i mean if they're making these kinds of
casting announcements maybe it'll
actually happen but this is a project
that has been morphing for a while
because
there was supposed to be a
gremlins 3 for a long time and then
there was going to be a prequel movie
and now it's apparently morphed into an
animated series like
nobody can seem to decide what they want
to do with the gremlins ip
and i'm not entirely
sure
why you'd go animated with gremlins
because like part of the appeal of
gremlins is like they act like slapstick
cartoons in real life
or at least that's part of the appeal
for me and it's part of why i like the
second one better than the first one but
just going animated i don't
i don't know what the appeal is at that
point
matthew lillard says the ultra instinct
shaggy meme is canon
i
you know what
you know what i've always liked matthew
lillard
i've i've always thought he was a very
entertaining guy and a better actor than
people give him credit for
lord of the rings the rings of powers
female dwarves will have beards
according to producer
yay
i mean like that kind of feels like
an embodiment of why i don't really care
about
about this stuff like i'm not the kind
of person who
has an opinion on whether or not
it's right or wrong that the female
dwarves have beards like okay do what
you want it's a movie
uh i'm honestly shocked that was never a
1990s gremlins animated series that
would have been the time for it they
were turning almost everything into an
anime series back then attack of the
killer tomatoes had an animated series
the live-action scooby-doo movies were
never good i didn't say those were good
i said he's a better actor than people
give him credit for that's a separate
conversation
all right let's see
i am groot trailer reveals first look at
the adorable guardians of the galaxy
spinoff i did see that trailer it is
cute i don't think i have too much
thought other than it being cute i think
it i think it's very smart that it's a
series of
animated shorts as opposed to like a
proper
like series with any kind of ongoing
story so and like given that they're
calling them animated shorts i mean
these things could be as short as like
seven or eight minutes which might be
the ideal length so at least if they're
going to do it they seem to be going
about it in an intelligent way
marvel's what if
season two announced for early 2023
alongside season three confirmation
okay
i didn't like what if
all that much there was a couple that i
kind of liked but
um yeah
um
i like snyder's films fine i think uh
his stuff is fun not world breaking
incredible uh they're fun and to me at
the end of the day that's all i can ask
for you know like that's fine and like
this isn't wow
it's uh it's debatable how much of it's
his fault because it's debatable how
much of it he ferments but like his fan
base does sour me on trying to like him
quite a bit because it becomes one of
those cases of like
if liking this
brings me closer to you folks i don't
think i want it it kind of becomes that
to a certain degree and like those are
people who who aren't going oh i like it
because it's fun they're they're going
oh this is the most brilliant piece of
work ever if you don't think so you're
an idiot and like again that's not
necessarily his fault
but
strong dynasty thank you for the super
chat absolutely no need to react to a
question that way okay strum
um
this is not the first time i've brought
up to miss ms wicked wolf about her
tendency to ask questions that i just i
don't know what to do with so this is a
bit of an ongoing thing she and i have
now
if you feel
that the interaction i had with someone
else was inappropriate
i don't know what to tell you
i would hope that the person who i was
speaking to would express that if
necessary
so
again i don't know what to do with this
comment either
i am trying to not get excessively
worked up
but
this is not a new interaction
that i had with her this has been a
little bit of an ongoing interaction
whether one were to consider it banter
or not you can have that as a separate
discussion but
i don't know what to say to you
if ms wicked will feels like i owe her
an apology
she may feel free to say so
so moving on
uh spider-man freshman year
that's another thing i don't really care
about i'm really really really tired of
spider-man in high school
like at this point especially in the
animated series because
every
single spider-man handmade series has
been him in high school
plus every single movie series now maybe
i'm partially biased because i started
actually reading the comics in the 90s
when he you know was an adult with a
career and an apartment and a wife
before marvel wiped that out so like i'm
just really sick of seeing him in high
school
and the fact that you know tom holland
is now too old to have that be the case
but they're going to cram in
an anime animator's like let's keep
doing high school like just do something
just do something else
do something other than the high school
for peter at least miles i'll give you a
pass to because he hasn't been used as
much but peter
oh that's enough already
and it's going to have charlie cox's as
daredevil which pretty much confirms
it's non-canon it would have to be i'm
pretty certain
okay
yes drama i am aware of david warner's
passing along with paul sorvino as well
so yeah
do old man peter no no because that
would be spider-man rain and that
that
that we do not need
captain
uh omni
can we at least admit um daredevil was
the best netflix marvel show for me it's
daredevil then jessica jones then
punisher then luke k then iron fitch
iron fitch iron fist
um
no
so
here's the problem i don't think any of
the shows were great consistently
i think daredevil had a great first
season
had
maybe
half of an almost good second season and
then a craps half of a second season and
a third season that was better but
nowhere near as good as the first
jessica jones had a
absolutely astounding
damn near flawless first season
and then a second season that didn't
know what it was doing in the third
season i didn't bother with so like i
don't know what
like
jessica jones season one is so he is so
much better than daredevil season one
daredevil season one is really good
that like even knowing that the show
kind of fell apart after that i
still am not prepared to just hand a
crown to
to um
uh to daredevil for that
i also can't fully judge punisher
because i got bored halfway through the
season i stopped
um
so you know
you also didn't mention the defenders
where you'd put that so now i'm curious
uh
jack harrow thank you very much for uh
becoming a member i greatly appreciate
that
tara statler i've been out of the loop
for a while because of life so just
saying hi well very happy to hear the
see you here
all right um
where were we
uh more rings of power stuff i'm going
to skip it
more gremlin stuff casting randall park
cool
glad he's working moving on x-men 97 to
premiere on disney plus in fall 2023 i
won't have an opinion on that until
there's a trailer i really kind of need
to see how in keeping with the previous
90s anime series they're doing it
because
i know it's unpopular in my age range
but the original cartoon was not that
good
like the the theme was the theme was an
absolute banger but
other than that
it was not very good
the animation was subpar the voice
acting was not very good and the scripts
were okay as adaptations go
but
i i need to see a trailer i'm hoping
what they're going to aim for is a bit
like
kind of like a cartoon version of what
the video game the teenage mutant ninja
turtles shredders revenge did which is
to make it very much updated but make it
feel like how you remember the old thing
as opposed to actually being like the
old thing
marvel zombies on disney plus will have
the gore and splatter you want from a
zombie show cool one more reason for me
not to bother watching it
tails from the walking dead gets his
first full trailer at san diego comic
con tales of the walk how many
hey
how many
how many walking dead shows are there
because there's walking dead
there's fear the walking dead and
there's tales of the does amc have
literally anything else
is that the only thing that that network
makes anymore
do they ever do anything else
did i miss something
ah
bubbles
bubbles by
bimmy bell that's cute to say thank you
so much for uh the membership i
appreciate that
so let's see what else we got
yeah so like i don't care about this i
didn't even watch the original walking
dead after the first season
marvel reveals real life infinity stones
collection worth 25 million okay they're
just showing off now the walking dead
gets new trailer premiere date for
series how is that st how is that not
over
like the final
the final season of this show
started airing almost a year ago
how is it not done
oh my g oh
moving on
action figures mandalorian i'm not
really an action figures guy the one god
more walking death the walking dead
spin-off starring andrew lincoln's rick
grime
rick grimes and deny guerrero's
michonne announced for 2023 weren't they
gonna do a movie
uh oh it's replacing the movie great so
we're gonna have a fourth show
why
why some somebody
somebody named me a show that's
currently on amc that is not walking
dead related i challenge you
i thought the walking dead was cancelled
i i mean like i don't know if it was
canceled or just scheduled to end but
it's been ending forever
the walking de the
walking
dead was trying to walking dead more
like the
dead show that's still walking it didn't
work i get i give up
i wouldn't mind a nick fury show with a
cheesy 80 90s action feel
like imagine samuel jackson talking
around arnold type one-liners
could be fun it would have to be
animated though because the expense of
the aging sam jackson live action for a
whole show they'd never they'd never do
it
uh
so let's see i shared the trailer for
with one
i shared the trailer with one fourth
coming in you see program with you on
twitter interview with a vampire oh
that's amc
okay so okay so they have one they have
one other thing
kevin can f himself oh that's amc i
forgot about that i still want to check
that show out anyways moving along
street fighter 6 don't care won't play
it tmnt co-creator says it's humbling to
see the franchise evolve dude
the the thing's never gone away i don't
know what to tell you avatar studios
first movie will focus on
wait what
the first avatar the last airbender film
will focus on the original series hero
and wait are these live action
what is this
are they are they trying for the live
action again
like i get pretending that the m night
shyamalan thing didn't happen but
they created a whole studio for this
uh
okay
oh
okay like i mean
i know this is
again uncommon for um
for for people like me in in my line of
work and around my age to not to not
think avatar the last day or bender's
the end all be all
of animation or uh storytelling but
i i don't it's fine it's fine
it's perfectly good but i don't i don't
know ma'am
it's kind of thematically fitting a show
about zombies won't ever die i suppose
so but like in a really bitter way
there's an ambulant tv show starring
jody turner smith that's an amc show
i feel like i know that name but i don't
know who that is it's an animated film
so wait
if they're doing avatar animated movies
is it incontinuity
are they continuations
what what are these things
i have i have all these questions and
yet at the same time i don't care about
the franchise so i probably won't watch
them yet my brain is still like wait
what
uh
anyways
d d honor among thieves co-director says
upcoming film is new and fresh i don't
need to be new and fresh i just wanted
to be fun and the trailer was fun so
that's fine by me
keanu reeves is berserker or anime
confirmed for two seasons on netflix hey
if you can get those seasons in advance
you get those seasons in advance now i
like keanu reeves i think we're at a
point right now where we kind of all
agree keanu reeves is awesome but like
um
what he's able to bring as a performer
is a presence
not
fully
exemplified by just his voice
now i say that he did actually do quite
a good job with his part in
um
toy story 4 except that like that was
comedic and cartoonish and like judging
by this image this is gonna be all
dour and um
and serious i'm like he can do that
but a lot of what he does that makes it
work is
not
his voice
so i don't know about this
who doesn't like keanu reeves oh yeah
keanu reeves
he's a good guy
not amc but amazon prime but amazon
prime are excited for the league of
their own series okay actually you know
what pirates i'm glad you brought that
up because that's not going to be on
here but i did actually check the
trailer for that it's pretty good i had
like one tiny concern but then i double
checked and it alleviated it
i had one concern that
if they were basing i know they're
basing it on you know the actual
formation of the all-american girls
baseball team etc
but
um i i was a little bit concerned seeing
the direction some of it was going
if these were going to be inspired by
specific real-life people like some of
the characters in the film were but
looking into it that does not look like
uh it's going to be the case so then
they're not mucking about with the
history of actual people so i'm actually
okay with that um
so
yeah the trailer trailer
looked really good for that actually and
that might that might be the first prime
show i go out of my way to try and watch
um
so
yeah
yeah uh so come and be coming back to
comic con though uh transformers earth
spark voice cast i don't watch
transformers never really have batman
and spawn are crossing over again
why
dc and image comics are bringing back
one of the classic 90s crossovers batman
and spawn will face off again
revealed during the jim lee and friends
panel at comic-con comic will be a
48-page one-shot written by todd
mcfarlane drawn by greg capullo
okay i mean i'm sure i'm sure todd needs
the money because
he's still got lawsuits to pay off
um
i mean he here's the thing
on the one hand
i would kind of go like
dc especially has had really bad luck in
bringing back
uh older
comic writers to like revisit stuff
um and actually i don't think todd even
wrote
that crossover i think frank miller did
and he just drew it
like todd's not a great writer
that's a that's a weird
but then he had like the original was
just kind of silly so like
it's already a silly crossover so like
what's the most damage it can do none
there's no integrity in the idea so
whatever
well i'm trying to reveal definitive
documentary with fan funded legion okay
sure
you keep telling yourself that chat
dragon ball super superhero new detail
revealed i don't watch it daniel craig
seemingly wants to be a guest star on
archer
that might actually get me to watch the
show again
it's god i forget that archer's still
going because it's one of those shows
that i kind of bounced off well i'm not
fully bounced off of but i just
it got past the point of um
of it being worth it for me to go out of
my way
uh anymore so i just kind of stopped
uh just accept you are an avatar heretic
so we can burn you at the stakes
[Laughter]
yeah no
try me come at me no don't really i'm
i'm
oh i'm exhausted i'm stressed and i'm
overworked and i'm not saying that
because i can't take you on i'm saying
that because i won't be able to control
myself and you'll all get more hurt than
uh that should really be happening
uh
a movie i want to get a second chance is
dracula untold with luke evans because i
think he deserves so much better than it
got if you've never heard of his
basically a better morbius i have heard
of it i never got around to it
why is shatner still getting work
because he's a name in a very
recognizable voice
uh star wars costume reveals new story
details for andor series i am not the
kind of person to try and sparse
to try and parse story details from
costume reveals we're moving on shazam
fury of the gods i
did not really like this trailer very
much
it did not do all that much for me
and it's hard for me to nail down why um
although to be fair
the trailers for the first one didn't
really do much for me either and i did
ultimately like largely end up enjoying
that
but
this didn't do much for me and something
feels a little off that so far all the
villains we've seen and so far as i can
tell from looking it up all the villains
are women
and they seem to be
mad at a male character for stealing
their power and that just feels
weird
to me
i don't know
i don't know what maybe i'll feel
different when i um
when i know more about the plot but that
trailer didn't do a lot for me
extreme x-men returns to marvel with
original cree what
what
legendary writer chris claremont is
reviving the fan favorite extreme x-men
no that's a terrible idea
look look i love chris claremont and his
uh his impact on comics in general and
the x-men in particular undeniable i've
seen him talk at comic cons
really interesting guy
this is a bad idea
so i kind of mentioned it already with
the
spawn batman thing but like
you want to look at dc and when they've
had people like frank miller or
neil adams was it neil adams
or was it i think it was neil adams they
like had these classic batman writers
come back and do it again and and like
it doesn't work
like it really doesn't and claremont
you know i i like the guy's work but his
work is also of a time his work is dated
and not even like 90s his work is 80s
dated
i love claremont i love a lot of the
characters that he introduced i adore
some of the things he wanted to do that
he wasn't allowed to do
but i don't know about this
yikes
uh
uh was there anything you like from
comic-con unless i miss something it
doesn't seem like it i i mean like
there is some and we'll get to some of
it but like they announce a lot they
announce a lot at comic-con
um
and so just by volume yeah a lot of it
isn't gonna isn't gonna do much for me
the rock showed up in full black autumn
costume during san diego comic-con nice
a black adam new trailer uh show justice
societies adam smasher dr fate cyclone
hawkman i have seen that trailer that's
a good trailer
um that one definitely did a lot more
for me than the shazam one did
house of dragons milly alcock says
dragon riding was like a mechanical bull
with leaf blowers
okay
house of dragons queen who never was is
based on real history
okay that i mean that's a background
lore thing that i'm not
that jay uh john
george
not j.r.r tolkien george r.r martin too
many r's you people
uh won't cameo in any game of thrones
shows until winds of winter is done so
he'll never cameo
but that's none of my business
bat we bat wheels to abuse the trailer i
tried watching this trailer it seems to
be like
pixar's cars but for bat
branded
things
it's a very strange idea
so i don't
i don't know who came up with that one
or what they were on
uh
uh so picard season three i still have
to see picard season two which i'm
nervous about because i heard i heard
like even from the most generous people
that like it started out okay but like
it was too long or stretched out or it
kind of fell apart
i won't lie though i saw the the teaser
for this third season and
it it it stirred something like as a fan
of
the next generation who watched it
i got my grandparents house
um growing up
yeah
yeah i know that that teaser did that
teaser did a little something for me and
yet he cameoed in a sharknado film
to be fair rowan they probably only had
to get him in front of a green screen
for that if he's got a cameo for game of
thrones they probably have to fly him
out to the shooting location
uh
he will never carry out that hurt vera
look i'm just saying these books were
supposed to be done
forever ago
star trek lower deck season 3
trailer teases a visit to deep space
nine okay
um i never got uh past the first episode
but that's that's because i don't have
paramount plus i've heard very good
things about lower decks but haven't
gotten back to it
star trek strange new worlds still
haven't seen it sandman reveals trailer
so
um
i i i did see this trailer
so
wish i wish
i was more excited for this than i am
i think the problem for me
is as someone who deeply loves the
original sandman comics and who has
already listened to
um at least the first part i need to get
to the second one uh the audible
adaptation of it
i don't
know what this is going to give me
because
the comic already has a visual component
and it's a visual component that the tv
show while not doing the zack snyder
watchman thing of literally using the
comic as a storyboard is very much
recreating it which is
cool but like i've seen it
so generally the main thing that an
adaptation like this would give me
would be seeing
actors interpret the parts except i've
already gotten that
from the audible adaptation
so
yeah i don't
i'm just not getting a lot
off of this and that's not me saying
it's going to be bad i don't think it's
going to be bad
but i don't think it's going to offer me
and like as someone who
loves this story as much as i do i'm not
sure what i'm going to gain out of
watching this show if that makes any
sense
have you watched the nevers i never did
get around to that one it was one of
those shows that i was like oh maybe and
then just never had the time
okay let's see
sandman artist did a unique ending
credits for every episode oh that's cool
dave mckean created a different end
credits for every episode okay now that
will be very cool to see
so dave mckean dave mckean um was the
cover artist he is a really interesting
artist and also like
his movie mirror mask
really should be watched by more people
than it had than it is
so
neil gaiman would love to see marvel's
1602 movie or series
i kind of want to see it as an animated
show
not sure why but that's my first
instinct
first trailer for anne rice's interview
with a vampire okay now that now this
this was interesting this was real
interesting seeing this um partially
because they've made the decision to
make louie if you're not familiar with
the interview with the vampire like you
only know the movie louie was brad
pitt's part and they're making louie
black now they're making some
accommodations to the character beyond
that from what i can tell because louie
in the original is basically a
plantation owner
so they're not just gonna have that
person now be black it looks like he
like runs a casino is kind of more what
they're going for with um
with this new one
i'll be really curious to see if they do
more alterations to
sort of bring a different angle to the
character and his story because one of
the things about louie
in
the book end in the uh previous
film adaptation
is that
he's
kind of a whiny rich white jackass
like he he has a royal plush of
royal plush royal flush of privilege
already being rich white male
um
and then he gets to live forever on top
of that and he's just very depressed
about it i think
giving that
giving that same storyline to a
character with a potentially very
different outlook and perspective
like a black man would have
has the potential to lead to some very
interesting alterations to the character
into the story i'll be curious to see if
they actually do that
or if they just make the one change to
have him be like the owner of a casino
so they can account for the race and
then never bring it up again that would
be disappointing
um if having mutants such as magneto
being too old uh considering options why
not just make an extended lifespan a
common trait among mutants also it
adapts real traits of evolution um so
the thing is the breathing nerdum is
referring to
my video talking about how the x-men
might get integrated and bringing up the
age of a holocaust survivor there's no
reason you can't do that the thing is
though that's such an
easy answer that i find it uninteresting
part of the reason i wanted to sort of
go through the thought experiment of
talking through other possibilities is
because that's so easy that it's kind of
boring not to say it's unusable or
unworkable
but i kind of wanted to explore other
options
the discord thank you carowind okay now
this i'm going to say right now this
stream's probably going to run over
we've got a bit more of this stuff to go
through but
i'm very quick
going to um
swap over to the council of geese
discord and check out the questions that
have been asked there by my patreon
supporters
uh and a reminder for anyone who's here
who is also on the patreon remember i
did implement a rule that i am only
going to take questions that were asked
prior to the start of the stream so i'll
be back in a minute
uh let's see
do you think we are either at or close
to a saturation point when it comes uh
to marvel in particular ah
i'm a bad person to ask because i'm
someone who because this is kind of my
living i feel like maybe a little bit
but i also feel an obligation to take in
everything that not necessarily
everybody else does
so i don't know how much pressure other
people feel to take in everything the
way that i do so i don't know how
widespread that is i'm starting to get a
little bit myself though
um
has the house of ideas run out of them
okay house of ideas being marveled no
actually i would say if anything they
have too many damn ideas they need to
slow down and give them more space and
room to breathe not have them clamoring
on top of each other
why is shazam and black adam and even
suicide squad two succeeding were
justice league and batman v superman
shot the bad um
i mean
a lot of reasons but ultimately here's
here's the thing here's the thing about
especially
the snyder versions of these things
regardless of what you think of them
whether you think they are overwrought
or whether you think they're brilliant
the snyder films
snyder in general has a very specific
appeal
that is not
especially mainstream
he was kind of an odd pick to attach to
mainstream properties like superman or
the justice league because what he does
has a very passionate following but not
a huge one
so
i think the the cleanest and quickest
argument to say was a mismatch of
creator to material but i'm not sure i'm
prepared to commit to that i have to
think about it more if you could write
any comic character anywhere which would
it be and why gut instinct mystique
because i love her and i think there's
just a lot that can be done with her
has the name the multiverse saga made
you rethink the likelihood of the x-men
being brought in from another universe
not at this time but i did even
acknowledge in that video that while
they are initially setting up barriers
that should prevent uh characters from
other universes just crossing over into
the main marvel cinematic universe
um that there isn't a reason that they
can't undo those later which might be an
outcome of the multiverse saga we'll see
a lot of the mcu is based on the
ultimate marvel universe one six one
zero i would suspect that we're looking
at something very similar to how that
universe ended the first time
or it's going to be an mcu version of
crisis on infinite earths i don't know
like again it's hard for me i'm not
always great at thinking about what
storylines they might do and plus i
don't love multiverse stories that much
so it's kind of hard to get my brain in
gear think about how they might or might
not go
um with the overall thing
i won't be in the chat had to go uh in
on my day off hope you're doing great
thank you very much do you think it was
helpful having kevin feige come out
basically reassure fans that yes we are
heading somewhere with all this we have
a plan
um
a little the thing is like when i when i
did my video asking is phase four in
trouble it wasn't that i was like i
don't i think they have no plan it was
that this phase in particular has not
had much structure
to it and that is an absence whether
there is a plan for where to go later
that doesn't change the fact that that's
how phase four has felt so for me
personally it doesn't really matter one
way or the other but for people who
might have been concerned that there was
never gonna feel like a plan again yeah
it was probably helpful
uh will the attempt to combine the mcu
tv show plot developments and the films
be the series undoing uh for the
latter's much larger audience
potentially potentially if they lean on
it too hard which i i think it's
arguable they already did with
multiverse of madness oh would you then
address in the question my partner knew
nothing uh re uh the one division story
and her reaction after watching welding
versus madness was she had no reason to
be emotionally invested in wanda's
damaged quest for these children last
she saw her was end of end game and she
understood her rate and where she
understood her rage but not here yeah
yeah
uh and confession to being someone who's
never watched an episode of stranger
things i have so much uh backing
up because of work and life getting in
the way of geekiness is it even worth
getting going back to start it
i
i think the first season is excellent
extremely excellent
i'm not on the same page as everybody
else with the other seasons especially
this most recent one which a lot of
people claim to love and i
really did not like there are aspects
and elements of late season that are
great but it's not most of it um so i i
i would say at the very least give
season one a shark because even as
someone who has not loved everything
since then i think season one is worth
watching if you are into that kind of
um that sort of vibe that era that uh
that sense of mystery and other
worldliness i think it's really good
uh would you prefer the new daredevil
show to follow directly off the existing
continuity of the netflix show
only make passing reference to it or
completely retcon the events of the
previous series entirely i expect what i
expect i don't really
what i expect and what i think i would
prefer
is to is to go with that middle option
there will be minor references to it it
will not it will not
heavily base its story off it i do not
expect elektra the hand ever show up
um nor do i expect them to retcon it
because bringing in charlie cox to then
just retcon it i i think they i think
marvel knows enough to know that that's
going to rub a lot of fans the wrong way
but i don't expect them to be doing
heavy continuity stuff
that having been said that may change
slightly depending on how well the show
does on
now that they've got the netflix stuff
on their own streaming platform i don't
know we'll see
do you think it would be a good idea to
reintroduce the other defenders
characters in that show
uh some of them
i don't know about jessica jones only
because like
her first season was excellent but it
really felt like she worked telling that
story and
that they never figured out what to do
with her since then that doesn't say you
can't figure something else out but i'm
not super eager to bri for her to come
back just because i feel like they told
the best story she's gonna they're gonna
be able to tell with her uh luke cage
absolutely they should absolutely bring
back luke cage
um and do not bring back iron fest bring
back luke cage bring back misty knight
bring back colleen wing
would be my preference
and drop the rest of it
i don't need that punisher and i don't
need a lot of that other stuff okay i am
now back uh in the main chat
so let me just take a look here real
quick
uh personally i don't think making the
villains of shazam to women would be a
problem but maybe i'm missing something
here to explain okay so
logan there's a very especially if
you're going to deal with old mythology
greek mythology and things like that
one of the
sort of frustrating things about it is
that
um
a lot of it basically always painted the
female deities as
bitter and spiteful
especially of
mortals granted power i mean that's the
entire concept behind
uh hera's hatred of hercules so
and and like it goes a lot of other
places along the same lines and it's
it's an aspect of mythology i don't need
reiterated in a modern retelling if that
makes sense
uh but anyways let's see fun fact neil
gaiman once had to talk the cops out of
arresting e m banks when he while maybe
drunk decided to try and climb the wall
of a hotel at a sci-fi conference was
taking place in
that's a good story
um you know uh the way you said you'd be
judging corinthian and desire because
they're the rules you want to play
that's how i feel about santiago in
interview with the vampire interesting
yeah it does impact your enjoyment
doesn't it
all right um
we're all
we're up to eight o'clock already all
right let me get back to these we
haven't even touched much of marvel yet
uh dragon prince season four i haven't
watched it past the first season
black adam dwayne johnson draws booze
for his superman response oh somebody
asked who would win black adam or
superman that would yeah whatever
um
ant-man of the lost quantomania poster
first proper look at kang
uh
okay
mystic quest returns for i don't even
know what that is
okay something on apple tv
marvel teases massive avengers finale
and jonathan oh that's in the comics
okay i haven't been reading the comics
cool she-hulk black panther will
conclude phase four uh the mcu and phase
five revealed okay yes
um
i did uh i did see about that and we'll
get into that a little bit more in a
minute
the uh the newer trailer for she-hulk
was better
the effects still aren't great
uh but they are a little better than
they were
daredevil born again announced during
san diego comic-con yeah i am curious as
to how
how that's gonna pan out
um actually hold on
let me see something here
uh with shazam does the fact that the
good guys include two female characters
affect the dynamic at all potentially
but it's also potentially a complicating
factor if you know anything about how
mary marvel has been handled in the
comics up to this point so again we'll
see
um all right so like here's the list for
what makes up phase five so it's ant-man
and the lost quantomania secret invasion
guardians of the galaxy volume three
echo loki season two the marvel's blade
iron heart agatha coven of chaos did
they retitle it um daredevil born again
captain america new world order
thunderbolts i know they announced um
some
avengers stuff but that's apparently
going to be phase six
i think
at least for me
a surprising amount is gonna end up
riding on
ant-man and the wasp because i really
wanna see
um i i need to see more of this version
of kang because i really liked
i i really liked what we got of kang and
loki
but knowing that we're going to be
dealing with variants of him
um
that that means that he may not be
playing the character the same way
and i'm hoping he'll still have that
same flavor because i really like
jonathan major's performance in loki i
liked it a lot um it's nice that blade
finally has a date
about dang time
uh it's about in time
a lot of stuff is vague spring summer
summer
okay
um
yeah boy they they are back to backing
these
series again secret invasion spring two
shows in summer probably one right after
the other then iron heart the fall
ah i really do worry about this stuff
being too much and coming too fast i i i
worry about
disney plus being used for this constant
feed of content i don't know
uh born again yeah mahershali mcu got a
release date yep new trailer saw it said
it was better
secret invasion coming to z plus next
spring yeah i went over all these dates
yeah the thunderbolts i kind of glossed
over i'm
so we don't know a lot about that at i
guess
that is probably gonna it
it's looking like it's gonna be made up
of whoever um
julia louis-dreyfus characters pulling
together which so far would include
elena
zemo
and uh john walker
which
would be an odd group to rap out on
i don't know might depend on who else
fills out the uh
the team i'm also i'm also presuming
i'm interested uh in seeing how ant-man
3 will portray modoc uh for my money i
will bet you modoc will be
fairly minor and almost like a uh
oh here's here's what the heroes are
currently dealing with and then he gets
dealt with and then they deal with kang
or like kang is behind modoc or
something like that
i'm so looking forward to more john
walker discourse
so many people seem to not get what was
being done
with that character it was kind of
frustrating
and captain america new world order
i i i am i i want i want this to be good
and i'm hopeful i
people in general seem to have kind of
soured on
um falcon and the winter soldier and
really i think the only thing that's
that is weak about it is the flag
smashers some of the specifics there but
the stuff with sam
and with bucky and yes even with john is
really good
there's a lot of good stuff there
so
first look at came the conqueror and
modoc
uh yeah so there's a whole bunch of
footage
show that hasn't been made public yet
and there's all these write-ups on it
but you can't find it at least not
bootleg and again i'm not gonna even
gonna try and find it to pull it up
because
uh it'll get the stream shut down
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 new
trailer shown that one's not going to go
public james gunn talked about this
because he said um
the effects
aren't finalized enough for it to be you
know watched and rewashed and gone over
um
uh
sort of um
god what's the frame frame by frame i
lost words for some reason
so it was comfortable showing it at the
com but not like where people are going
to watch it on 4k screens and go over
every bit of it which honestly that's
fair enough
more stuff about the releases marvel
phase six okay
phase six let's take a look at this
thing
can i get a list can i get just a list
oh come on
dang it
all right so it starts off
with the fantastic four
and ends with avengers kang dynasty and
avengers secret wars
now uh it is actually kind of a big deal
that they finally
told us when the avengers as a
property
uh come back
sam elliot is that the law and order guy
no that's sam watterson
sam elliott is somebody else um
so anyways
um
with the the fantastic four kicking
things off i'll be interested to see how
they integrate that but it is more
interesting to me that they said when we
get new avengers so i think honestly
that probably helped even more than
feige saying we're building to something
to just be able to say like look
here's where you will get new big team
up movies uh just knowing where that
will land kinda helps
um
and
again i'm hopeful like
i i don't i don't think
i can understate how much i liked
jonathan mages as kang in loki and
understand kang is not a character i
find interesting
at all and jonathan majors really the
only thing i'd seen him in was lovecraft
country playing one of the less
interesting parts so i didn't know what
he was going to bring to it but i loved
what he did with that part
so much
and as long as they don't make him
flatten it
and make him more generic make him play
it more generically as long as they
don't do to him what they did to
christopher eccleston for thor the dark
world
i could be really into
them making him the kind of the spine
across um
phases five and six
potentially this could work
this could work we'll see
did you see the high evolutionary in
comic con the actor came and in costume
and in character he was fun but sinister
nah i missed that
uh let's see
uh black panther wakanda forever that
was a good trailer that i did a reaction
to that was the one trailer i did a
reaction to
that's on the break room of geeks if you
don't check me out there
uh
tena cuerta hope i didn't butcher that
confirmed to play namor yep uh yeah i'll
be really see where that goes oh and
this is it we're almost done oh i'm not
going over by that much avengers and
game directors joe and anthony russo are
not directing the kang dynasty or secret
war so
since that
since then
and i i want to thank carowind for this
because she brought
that this to my attention
[Music]
that they did confirm a director for at
least the first of the avengers
and that is destin daniel [ __ ]
uh who directed chongqi and legends
legend of the ten rings
which makes sense i mean that's the same
way the uh the russos came to the job
they started out
working the
captain america films
and
they um
they impressed marvel well enough that
they they were handed the reins to the
avengers so yeah that was uh
yeah that that that works i'm down for
that
you notice there's a ton of marvel news
and little dc news well yeah they don't
have nearly as much in the works for one
thing
me thinks that dc is taking their time
and not doing what marvel is doing which
is cranking them out extremely fast it's
not really fair to compare the two at
this point logan
because they're not anywhere near in the
same position
because at this point like here's the
let me put it this way
if dc
had as solid a foundation with as many
super hit and well-loved movies as
marvel had they would be cranking out
just as much stuff
the only reason they slowed down was
because because they had to figure out
what was going wrong whereas marvel has
not had to do that so like
you're just so like if this is the
racetrack you're judging the activities
of somebody who's
back here to somebody who's over here
like
there are different points in this whole
thing
uh i really don't like this too much
narrative with the mcu people are
celebrating the casting of namor more
lgbt rep complaining about too much is
missing the force for the trees
to oh
oh you mean people complaining about too
much diversity yeah that
well yeah whatever
um
there we go
so i think that'll just about wrap it up
i was afraid we were going to go to like
um
8 30 or later but
got that done in uh in decent time all
things considered um i need i need to
get back
did you already talk about marvel
zombies i kind of skipped over it or
because
i don't like
marvel zombies i mean what i will grant
is i liked what
um
i liked what
the what if version did with marvel
zombies more than what the comic book
version of marvel zombies are
but that's just comparative because i
loathe
i loathe
the marvel zombies comics
i really really hate them
um so just the fact that it wasn't just
like those was already a good thing so
um
if this new one is based more on the
what if that's better i still don't want
it
but that's me
since bree larson uh is in every movie
uh ddc is directed it's fair to say
carol danvers will be a major player in
kang dynasty
i mean
one would assume that they're building
to that anyways but we'll see
uh yes thank you for the reminder
carowind so twitch tomorrow morning 10
30 eastern daylight time um i'll be
getting back into uh spirit fairer
because i need something um relatively
chill while i try desperately to finish
off some editing which is also what i
need to get done
so
there
will be a new video here
on this channel tomorrow at noon
announcing a new project
that kicks off
on saturday
so uh you have that to look forward to
in uh in any case thank you so much for
uh tuning in someday i'd love to see a
random why you load marvel zombies maybe
someday not right now not right now i
got too much to do
um but thank you so much for joining me
and i hope that you had fun that you
have a good rest of your night hope to
see some of you uh twitch.tv council of
geeks in the morning and more than
anything i want you to remember that you
are
beautiful you are valid
and you are loved
you're the council
i'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
mccavity